donc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh [
Musique]
d'accord bon garçon
[Musique]
ohhein
comment appelez-vous ce rasage
raser ma barbe après un an
de l'avoir sur je
suis je suis totalement déprimé j'ai aussi
pour me couper les cheveux, nous allons me raser la
barbe euh
pour faire des photos supplémentaires sur
hunter killer
j'ai littéralement ça depuis
décembre dernier euh ça fait bien plus longtemps que
ça aussi et je suis totalement déprimé et
que font-ils juste  tout droit
oh
[Musique]
oh mon dieu
regarde c'est
parti, c'est parti viens
ici
merci tu
pourrais t'embrasser
je t'aime
bonjour
bébé
c'est
[Musique]
des questions
toi